[MUSIC PLAYING]
PENDO O'DONOHOE: So
absolutely delighted to have
Zim visit us today,
and talk to us
a little bit about how
she's managed to build
an unconventional company.
So Zim, first and foremost, tell
us a little bit about yourself.
Because you've got
an impressive resume,
which goes from being a
biologist to various things.
And finally, entrepreneurship.
So tell us how that's
all come about.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: OK.
Ooh, where do I start?
OK.
So I was born and
raised in Minnesota.
I was one of those kids
that loved to get lost.
So I was always
wandering around.
My mom often tells me the
story of how I let myself out
of the apartment that we
were staying at when I was--
I think I was one.
It was the middle of the winter.
And I walked around
the parking lot
until child services
came to pick me up.
And so she likes to
tell me that story.
And so I linked that to--
kind of to what I'm doing now.
I'm kind of a wanderer at heart.
After I left Minnesota, I
was about eight years old.
I moved to North Carolina,
and I got into biology
my freshman, sophomore,
junior year of college.
And at the age of
19, I cloned a gene.
I was one of those, like
nerdy kinds of kids.
I was crushing fruit flies and
was doing really weird things.
And so that led me to
traveling around the state
to talk about my research.
I also teamed up
with my best friend
who did a lot of anti-tobacco
work at the time.
And we traveled
around the country
talking to young people
about big tobacco
and how to protect
ourselves against them.
And so after that,
I did some travel.
I went and I moved to DC.
I moved to San Francisco
to organize churches--
or pastors of those churches
in the Fillmore District,
which is the oldest black
neighborhood in San Francisco.
And then, I moved back to North
Carolina for my senior year.
I had five years of university.
I stayed an extra year.
And I started an organization
to help open a civil rights
museum.
It was a museum that hadn't been
open for, I think, 14 years.
Come on in.
Sorry.
I definitely put
you on the spot.
I'm sorry.
And so my senior year,
this museum opened.
And I decided that I wanted
to do something a little bit
different.
Instead of traveling and
living in San Francisco and DC,
I wanted to try
something international.
So I applied for this
program, and I got it.
And I sold everything that
I owned after I graduated
college, and I moved to India.
So I was in India for
a little over a year.
I learned Hindi.
And I lived on a train
for a portion of the year.
So I was just doing all of
these really interesting things.
And I went to India with
braids similar to this.
And so as my diaspora
folks know, at some point
the braids have to come out.
So I took the braids out.
And I didn't know what
to do with my hair.
The hair of a lot of Indians
was very different from my own,
and I didn't have anything
to take care of it.
So my hair started breaking.
And I thought to
myself, you know,
I don't see any people
who look like me.
I don't see any
travelers or any ex-pats
who I can talk to about
what's happening with my hair.
And so the idea for Travel
Noire was born there.
But I sat on it for two years.
I traveled through Asia.
I spent all of my
money, and ended up
broke back home in Southern
California at my mom's house.
And so it's kind of--
Travel Noire kind of
started out of that.
So it was the seed planted
while I was living in India,
and then I kind of
came back to the US.
My mom tried to get
me into medicine.
As again, all of my diasporic
folks here, you all know.
So I'm Nigerian.
And for my mom, you were
either a doctor, a lawyer,
an engineer, or a failure.
Like anything
else, there was a--
there was this little box that
you kind of had to fit in.
And so when I came home
after spending all my money
traveling, my mom
was like, yeah,
so here's this nursing program.
Here is this doctor's program.
Here's this post-bac program.
And after six months, I was
like, all right, I love you,
mom.
But.
I'm going to move
to San Francisco.
So I had $300 in
my bank account.
And somebody offered
a couch for me
in San Francisco
on Treasure Island.
I don't know if anybody's
been to San Francisco,
but there's this little
island called Treasure Island.
between San Francisco
and Oakland,
if you were to cross
the Bay Bridge.
So I lived there.
I slept on a couch/bed
for six months.
And I worked four jobs.
And I had this
really interesting--
like I sold luxury sunglasses.
I was a nanny, which
was very short-lived.
And I helped my friend
start her company.
And what else did I do?
And I was an intern
at a startup company.
And being an intern at
that startup company
was what kind of
fine-tuned this idea
that I had for Travel Noire.
So that is a very long
answer to your question,
but I hope it gives
some background.
PENDO O'DONOHOE: Absolutely.
And it sounds like you chose
the failure option when
it came to what the
Nigerian parents wanted,
which is-- hence you
founding Travel Noire.
But tell us a little bit about
what Travel Noire actually
is, what it does, and who
your target audience is.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Sure.
So started Travel Noire in 2013.
And this was after not seeing
travelers who looked like me.
If you go to any store, you
pull any travel magazine
off the stands, you'll never
see somebody who looks like me.
You'll never see a black girl
in Italy, or in whatever.
And what that meant
for a lot of people
was, if they didn't see somebody
who looked like them traveling
in all these different
places, they then
thought that it might have been
dangerous for them to travel,
or that travel might
not be for them,
or that travel is only
for the rich and famous,
like Beyonce and
Jay-Z, or whatever.
And so I wanted to bring
that down to earth.
I mean, when I was
living in India,
I was flying on Air Asia for
$8 to Malaysia from India.
I mean, it was crazy.
And so I wanted
people to know this.
And so Travel Noire started
out as an editorial site.
So we had about 100 writers who
lived all over the globe, who
shared their love of travel.
And what it was like being
a person of color while they
traveled.
I remember being in--
I think I was in
the Netherlands.
And somebody asked
me, they said, well,
what's the difference
between a black person
traveling, a black American
traveling, and a white American
traveling?
And I told them--
I gave them a
couple of examples.
But one that stood
out was in China,
when I would go into a store
and I'd ask her for face wash,
they'd give me skin
whitening cream.
Or a kid would come
and try to rub off
my skin thinking it
was dirt and there
was like white underneath.
Or people who would
constantly pull my hair.
There were all of these
different experiences that
were very unique to a
certain subset of people
that nobody was talking about.
So we started out as
an editorial site,
and then we grew from that to
hosting live classes about how
to get your boss to let you
work from anywhere in the world,
or how to get paid to travel.
And we started building
an audience that way.
And one thing that I
learned that we did--
we didn't make
money for 18 months.
So 18 months, we spent the
time building an audience.
And we just offered
a lot of free things,
a lot of free classes.
And when we did end up selling
a product, we sold out of it.
And so we started as
an editorial site.
We started doing a
lot of free things,
And Then we launched
Travel Noire Experiences
in July of 2015.
Travel Noire
Experiences, they're
small group experiences.
About 14 people.
They're 14 strangers from
anywhere in the world.
They meet in one of
our seven destinations
and we take them for
the ride of their life.
It was inspired by
my time in India.
My time in India was
awesome, but it was also
very challenging.
Who in here has been to India?
All right.
So you all know
that India is not--
some people used to tell me,
oh, like India's like traveling
to like any other Asian country.
Or it's like traveling
to any other country.
And it's not.
It's like very difficult.
It's very challenging.
You either love
it or you hate it.
And I thought to
myself, if India had not
been so challenging, I
would not have grown so much
or been so transformed by it.
And so I thought
to myself, how can
I compress that into seven
days where you challenge people
enough that you know
they don't hate you,
because it's a vacation.
But you also build in
moments of transformation.
So on any one of
our trips, you'll
find days that challenge,
days that lift you up,
days that may make you upset.
Like in Cape Town for instance,
we talk a lot about apartheid.
In Jobar, we talk a
lot about apartheid.
And we go and talk to people.
And we go into people's
homes and we cook with them.
And so the idea behind
those experiences
is that they are an experience.
It's like you're living
just like a local, which
isn't easy in a lot of places.
And so we launched
TN Experiences.
We run about 60 trips a
year across 5 continents.
Each trip comes with a
private photographer.
And that's because I didn't want
people to look through travel
through their phone.
I wanted people to be present.
And I wanted people to
really enjoy the moment,
and enjoy conversations,
and not try and gram
everything, or Snapchat
everything, or tweet things.
And so those are
the experiences.
They're typically seven
days, eight nights.
Seven days, six nights.
And then, we launched
Compass earlier this year,
which is a platform that
helps travelers travel better.
So if you want to move abroad,
if you want to travel solo,
if you want to move
your family abroad,
we have resources that we
deliver every single week
to help you do that.
So that's what Travel Noire is.
And I always tell everything
in a story, just so you know.
So sometimes, the answers are
very long, but bear with me.
PENDO O'DONOHOE:
We'll remember them.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU:
You'll remember them.
PENDO O'DONOHOE:
So that step off
towards being an
entrepreneur is obviously one
that some people are
a bit nervous about.
How did you find it?
What emotions did
you go into when
you were making that decision
and actually deciding that this
was going to be for you
well the decision was made for
me I didn't make the decision.
So two days before
my birthday actually
my boss sent me an
email firing me.
So it was two days
before my birthday,
and I think two weeks
before a vacation
that I was supposed to take.
And that kind of forced
my hand, you know?
I was planning on leaving
a couple of months later,
but it was such a
blessing because had I
left a couple of months
later on my own terms,
I wouldn't have
gotten the severance.
But since she fired me, I was
able to keep that severance,
which went into
this pocket of mine
to help me kind of live
for the next 18 months
that Travel Noire
didn't make any money.
And so entrepreneurship,
I would say,
is probably the hardest
thing I've ever done.
Anybody who is an
entrepreneur or who has been
will probably say
the very same things.
I mean, just a couple of
months ago, I was like,
what if I just give it all up?
And just buy a
little house in Italy
with no internet,
no electricity,
and just look at the water?
I'll be fine.
I'll be quiet.
I'll live a nice,
quiet existence.
Every entrepreneur has talks
like that with themselves.
And it's a matter of
really understanding
your mission and what you are
called to do in this world.
And it's hard.
It's not easy.
We have a team.
I have a team of full-time
folks of eight people.
But you count all of
our contractors in
and that brings it up to 30.
You're holding these
people's lives in your hand.
And you know, every
move that you make,
their livelihood depends on it.
And that pressure of having
to figure out whether or not--
you have this really
great idea, but it's not
financially feasible.
But you want to do it.
You can't do it because
you have these--
you have the livelihoods of
these people in your hands.
People who have families.
People who are
considering proposing
to their significant others.
You have all of these
different things.
And so it's been a challenge,
but it's also pretty beautiful.
I mean, you build
something out of the dust.
And one of the things that
I thought was really cool,
last year in January, we
had a team of four people.
And got a tweet one
morning in January
that we had been named
by Fast Company as one
of the most innovative
companies in the world.
And it was kind of
mind-blowing because we
were such a small
team, but it was
kind of validating, too, that
anybody with an idea that
has a penchant towards
execution can really
do some good in the world.
And so that's what I've
learned about entre--
there's a lot that I've
learned around entre--
I could talk about it all day.
But it's really hard.
And I tell people.
People ask me what
their advice is
for want-to-be entrepreneurs.
And a lot of times, I
tell them not to do it.
And I know that's really
bad, but it really is hard.
And when you think
about entrepreneurs
that are charismatic
specifically,
they have a higher
rate of depression.
Being a charismatic
entrepreneur,
who are you going to talk
to when things go wrong?
If you have a significant
other, perfect.
But are there people
around you that
really understand the
perils and the plight
of being an entrepreneur?
And I know it's hard to
put into words for people
who aren't entrepreneurs.
But sometimes, it can
get really challenging.
But it's also beautiful.
So there's a balance.
So just to pick up on
your point around needing
to have other people
to talk to, who
have your mentors been over
your journey with Travel Noire.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Yeah.
So I have a group of advisers.
They all come from
different walks of life.
But I also have a
group of entrepreneurs
that I meet with maybe
four or five times a year.
These are entrepreneurs
from all over the world.
And we all come together
to talk about issues
and what we're going through.
And one thing that
I've learned is
that no matter how
much money you make,
you're still messed up.
Everybody still has problems.
Everybody has problems.
You think when you get into
a room with somebody who
has a $200 million company
that they're just going
to be like relaxing and maxing.
But it's just the problem's
magnified on a different scale,
on a different level.
And so that's one
thing that I've learned
is that your problems don't
go away when you got money.
They're still there,
just in different ways.
PENDO O'DONOHOE:
And congratulations
on being named one of
the Forbes 30 Under 30.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Thank you.
PENDO O'DONOHOE:
That's absolutely
fantastic from last year.
So apart from that particular
highlight, what other highs
have you had?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Other highs?
I would say having a team
of really cool people.
You know, it's always
great when you're
able to work with people that
you get along with and people
who are just a lot of
fun, who are grounded
in the same mission
that you're grounded in.
I can take a month
off and not have
to worry about anything
because they handle everything.
And so I think that that's
been the biggest blessing.
Launching Compass this year
has also been a big blessing.
I'm trying to think.
There have been so many highs.
I tell my team not to get
caught up on all of them.
So while we do celebrate
what we've got going on,
we are also still very rooted
in the work that we have to do.
Because we have more
people to reach.
And we have more
people that we want--
more people whose lives
we want to help transform.
And so we do celebrate the
wins, but then we go back
and we dive into the
work that we have to do.
PENDO O'DONOHOE: And you
have hundreds of thousands
of followers on social
media at the moment.
So what role has
digital actually played
in helping build your brand?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Huge.
You talk about millennials
today and how much
our lives are kind of
intertwined with social media.
I remember I was first starting
the Travel Noire Instagram
account.
It was so hard to
find black travelers,
like I would sit and browse
on Instagram for hours
to find one photo.
And we would post
12 photos a day.
So if you can imagine, it
was a lot of hard work.
But over time, it got easier.
People liked seeing themselves
featured in different places.
So that made it
easier for people
to kind of tag their photos.
So it's been such a great help.
In fact, people,
when they tell me
they've heard of Travel
Noire, the first place
that they say that they've heard
of Travel Noire is Instagram.
And so we use Instagram as
like the top of the funnel.
And so a lot of times, when we
need somebody to do something,
we have a call to action,
we start on Instagram
or we start in email.
And we direct people
where we want to go,
which has been really cool.
PENDO O'DONOHOE: Great.
And sort of back
to more your travel
and personal experiences.
What's the craziest place
you've ever visited?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: The craziest
place I've ever visited?
Probably India.
I will always say India
for any crazy adventure.
Craziest place I've visited?
So my boyfriend and
I, he came to India
while I was living there.
And we took a bus, like
a 4 by 4 up to Kashmir,
which is the disputed territory
of India and Pakistan.
And it was so beautiful, though.
It was so beautiful.
But it was quite
treacherous getting there.
We had to sit in the--
it wasn't the trunk,
but it was like--
if you imagine a Jeep.
And you have the chair.
You have the driver's seat
and the passenger seat,
and then you have like
another row of seats,
we were in the back, like
where there were no seats, just
the floor.
So we were just sitting in the
back looking at the outside.
And we rode on this
canyon with no fence.
It was the craziest thing.
It was the craziest adventure.
People die on that road.
And you know, we
got stopped by--
there were either cows or
goats that were crossing
and it caused a
whole traffic jam.
And for those that have been
to India, you know how cows do.
They just do whatever they do.
And everybody just stops.
But it was cool.
It was fun.
PENDO O'DONOHOE: Great.
I'm just going to open
it up to the audience,
to see if anyone has got
any questions for Zim.
We've got a mike.
[INAUDIBLE]
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks so much, Zim.
I love the way that you
answer questions in stories.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I was
just wondering,
using what you know now, what
would you have told yourself
when you first decided
to start Travel Noire?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: That's
a good question.
Back than, hm.
I'd probably say have a
close relationship with God.
And I think that--
so when I first started
Travel Noire, I had a team.
But because we didn't
make any money,
we couldn't afford
to pay anybody.
And I think that the way that
I treated people back then--
it wasn't bad.
Like, I wasn't
yelling at people,
or kicking them, or
doing anything like that.
But I think that had I had a
closer and tighter relationship
with God, I would
have been much calmer.
I would have been
nicer to people.
And so I think that's probably
one of the big things,
because I had a team fallout
before we hired a new team.
So if you can imagine
running a company, and then
you lose your team.
And then you kind of
have to start over.
And then another thing that I
would say would probably be--
I don't know.
Sometimes, because
we're not out there,
like we're not hosting
a lot of events
or we're not at every
event, people kind of
see us as standoffish or a
little secretive, or whatever.
And it's not the case.
Maybe it's just like the ethic
or the ethics or the drive.
We just love our work and
we love doing good work.
And sometimes, we
just get consumed
in doing that good work.
But not being afraid to peek
out of the curtain every
once in a while and
say what's up to folks.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: How did
you find your team
when you were starting off
when you couldn't offer them
any money?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: So I think
everybody for the most part
has been really intrigued
with this idea about,
like working from anywhere, or
working for a travel company.
We have unlimited vacations
and we don't have an office.
And so obviously, we couldn't
pay people back then.
So before we could
pay people, I think
people were just
really attracted
to the brand and the
culture of the brand.
And people wanted
to be associated
with what we were doing.
So it wasn't difficult
to find a team.
I mean, it's always difficult
to find a quality, quality team.
But it wasn't challenging to
find people who loved travel.
Because back then,
not that there
was a small subset of
black folks traveling.
There were a ton, but we
weren't all connected.
And I think once people
found that nexus,
they kind of wanted to
gravitate towards it.
So some people were
like old friends
that I brought
into this project.
And some people-- we had
a fellowship program.
And the fellowship
program, I taught you
how to earn enough miles
for a free vacation anywhere
you wanted in the world.
And a lot of people
were like, oh, sure, OK.
You're not paying me,
but you're showing me
how to travel for free.
And that's like the
next best thing.
AUDIENCE: First of all, your
work on Instagram is amazing.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm one
of the people who
found you through Instagram.
So when you talk about
building of culture--
previously, I used
to work for a startup
and that's one of the biggest--
I guess starting is
pretty tough to do it.
How did you go about
building culture,
especially from Instagram?
Sort of getting
the follower base.
Because you've got
lots of travelers
that you're sort of
connected in there.
I guess you connected
a group of travelers
all over the world on Instagram.
I learned other peoples'
travels through that [INAUDIBLE]
Travel Noire.
So how did you go about
doing that and just creating
this community?
And then my second question
was about the locations
that you have already listed.
How do you go about selecting
those and organizing
the experiences?
For one, I lived in Cape Town.
And most experiences you see
there is very touristy, which
is you don't learn about the
history and what's going on,
and the actual people
who live there.
So how did you go
about creating?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Yeah.
OK.
I have very short-term
memory, so I'm
going to try and
remember both of them.
OK, so the first question
was, how do we build culture?
Culture was an extension--
is an extension
of who we are as a team.
So right when I had
that team fall-off,
we had two people that stayed.
And so what I did was
I said, all right.
We got to build a
tighter culture.
So we had a summer
culture project.
And we worked.
We had, I think,
Friday all hands
on deck for like two months.
And we built out
the entire culture.
We built, all right.
We want unlimited vacations.
We want to be able to
work from anywhere.
I feel like now if I went back
to my team and said, all right,
y'all.
We're going to put
an office in Chicago,
they would like
revolt. They really
love being able to
work from anywhere.
We pay their cellphone bills.
Like We have all of
these different things
that we do to make it easy
to work for Travel Noire.
And so our culture was an
extension of who we are.
So everything is figureoutable
is one of our tenets.
And that just means
that if I can't find--
if I flip this chair
over, even if it doesn't
have a name on it,
I will find out
who made this chair
some way, somehow.
And that's one of the
cultures of the team.
That's one of the tenets
for our culture of the team
is that if we can't find
a solution right away,
we figure it out.
And so every time we are
considering candidates,
we run them through a really
interesting questionnaire.
I don't know if it's similar.
Google used to have
something where it was like,
so how many pennies are in
the Empire State Building,
or something like that.
PENDO O'DONOHOE: We got
rid of those questions.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Yeah.
So you got rid of
those questions.
We actually have that.
We have the pennies
question in one of our forms
because it goes back
to that everything
is figureoutable value.
Instead of telling
me what the number is
for that particular-- like how
many pennies are in the Empire
State Building, you can ask
me questions like, is there
furniture in the lobby?
How many people are there?
Are the coins from the UK?
Are they American
pennies, like whatever.
It allows us to see who people
are without them telling us who
they are, if that makes sense.
So we also have one of our
values is be you, stay true.
Everybody on our team is weird.
Like the weirdest
people that I know.
And I'm also weird.
But I want people who come
into the Travel Noire team
to also feel like they
are welcoming their weird.
And it's OK to be weird
because we're all weird, OK?
It's like a very--
kind of like a familial vibe.
It's kind of almost how I
would imagine Google was back
in '90--
PENDO O'DONOHOE: [INAUDIBLE].
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Back in '98.
And so that's the
culture question.
For the destination
questions, sometimes we
choose places based
on where I've been
or where some of
my staff has been.
And then we go there.
We travel there.
And I remember
going to Cape Town.
Who's been to Cape Town?
All right.
So we got folks who
have been to Cape Town.
So when I landed in
Cape Town, I wanted
to build an experience
that I could relate to,
which was a black
Cape Town experience.
But when I landed in Cape
Town, I stayed in Camps Bay.
I don't know if y'all are
familiar with Camps Bay,
but it's like near the
water, near the ocean.
And the only people of color
that I saw were the help.
And I was like, hm.
So in order to
build an experience
that I can relate to, I have to
find people who look like me.
And so I was racking
my brain trying
to figure out how to build
a Cape Town experience that
was one that focused on
culture, meeting people.
And so I ended up
figuring it out.
And I remember we
were at a point
where we were trying to
figure out whether to include
Robben Island in the tour.
And I talked to
one of the guys who
grew up in Langa, which is the
township outside of Cape Town.
And I said, I'm kind of
torn between Robben Island
and the District Six Museum.
And we landed on
having those stories
told by the people
who lived them
themselves in the township.
And so we encouraged
people on their free day,
if they want to go to
Robben Island, to go there.
But the guards in
Robben Island don't even
like giving the tours there
because it-- remind you,
they're former prisoners
who spent their lives
in this prison.
And they're now
forced, because they
have to make a
living-- nobody will
hire them-- to
retell the stories
that were so painful for them.
And so when building
that experience--
and all of our
experiences, really--
we have to be very sensitive
to all of these things.
So people are paying for that
sensitivity, if you will.
So understanding the
issues as they exist.
People still go
to Robben Island,
and they find out
for themselves.
Just like in Bali.
We have an experience in Bali.
People go to the elephant--
they're not elephant farms,
but they're like the elephant--
not sanctuaries, but
the elephant places.
I don't know what
they're called.
But people go there, and
then they come back sad.
Like they realize for
themselves that this wasn't what
I expected.
But we get a lot
of questions like,
why don't y'all include
an elephant tour?
Why don't you do x?
Why don't you do y?
And it's our job to
be mindful and to be
sensitive to how the locals
really live their lives.
And how to create a
space where we're only
working with local vendors.
We're building up economies
and things like that.
So the mantra is travel to
meet people, not see things.
So traveling to have
conversations with people.
Sometimes, I know when
I've traveled in the past,
I would go to monuments
and take pictures.
But at the end of the
day, what I really
remembered about the trip
were the people that I met
and the homes that
people invited me into.
And the coffee shops we sat
at and talked and whatever.
And so that's kind
of the philosophy
that we used to build
those experiences.
Yeah.
You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So I have a question
around money.
It's one question, but
multiple questions pop up.
So [INAUDIBLE],, how can someone
transition from employment
to entrepreneurship?
Because [INAUDIBLE]
employment, you're
being paid at the end, at
least on a specific date.
So if you decide, you know what?
I'm just going to
follow my dream,
you need to be able
to generate revenue.
Because at the end of the
day, you're a human being.
You need a roof.
You need to eat.
You need clothes.
You need everything.
And you don't know how long
that business is going to--
how long the business
will take to grow
to be able to sustain the
current standard of living
that you have now.
So that's something
that I think.
And then again, the
question of passion.
And also, being-- maybe that's
not the right word to use,
but realistic.
So I'm passionate
about this idea.
But at the end of the day, look.
You got bills to pay, right?
So how do you manage?
Because that's the
conversation that you need
to have with yourself, right?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Yeah, for sure.
AUDIENCE: So how do
you go about that?
Basically, this
whole money thing.
And maybe the
[INAUDIBLE] question
would be, how do you know this
is the right time to stop?
Maybe you have a nice idea.
You're working on it, but the
money's just not coming in.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Yeah.
All right.
OK.
So first question was--
the first question was, I
know what you were getting at.
OK.
So when I was living in
San Francisco, after I
spent all my money traveling.
I lived with my
mom for six months.
I moved to San Francisco,
and I had all those jobs.
I had a $3 a day budget.
So it was either I used
that $3 for the bus or I
used it to eat food.
And with any startup--
well, not any startup, but a lot
of startups in San Francisco.
They had free food.
Just like y'all do at Google.
So I was able to
kind of offset that.
But $3 a day is not
a lot, you know?
At all.
And so that was the budget
that I had for six months.
So when you think
about-- and not
every entrepreneur's
journey is like that.
But a good number
of folks, when they
leave their high-paying
jobs, maintaining
that standard of living,
you have to reconcile that.
Because if you're
making six figures
and you are trying to start
a company that is making $0,
if you quit your job,
then you're not--
the numbers aren't
going to shake out.
So I remember after I
got fired from my job,
those checks stopped
coming, but I had saved--
I think I saved maybe,
like $15,000 or something.
But that was for the next 18
months that I had to live.
Like $15,000 for 18 months?
That's not a lot of money.
And so I had to move
out of my apartment.
I was living in San Francisco.
I moved out of my apartment.
And I just traveled
for six months.
And so there are lots
of different ways
that you have to reconcile
what your passion is
and your current
standard of living
and how comfortable you are.
You have to be comfortable
with being uncomfortable.
Otherwise, at the
first sign of hardship,
you're just going to quit.
And you're going to go back
to the high-paying job, which
I think is a lot-- it's a
danger for a lot of people.
They don't give their
business or their idea
enough time to really incubate.
I started Travel Noire while
I still had my full-time job.
So I started Travel
Noire in 2013.
I got my job in 20--
I started Travel Noire two
months after I got my job.
So all I needed was
that security net.
And I was like, OK.
Boom.
This idea, let's get it going.
I started Travel Noire
and I didn't quit until--
well, I got fired.
So I was forced into
entrepreneurship.
But I ran with that idea
while I had a steady paycheck.
I didn't quit the job, and
then start Travel Noire.
So I think that's also
something to consider.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I am also a huge
Travel Noire fan.
So you were talking about how
one of the main things that
gets you through the tough times
is knowing what your mission is
and hanging onto that.
So I'm wondering,
what is your mission,
personally or for the company?
And how did you come
about pulling it together?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: I looked
back at my thread.
So I took my mom to this, like
Oprah event a couple of years
ago.
And Oprah said,
what's your thread?
What is the thing
you were doing when
you were a child that you can
link to what you're doing now?
There was one story that
she gave of a girl who
loves to be organized.
And she got a file cabinet
for her seventh birthday
and was the happiest
person ever.
And now, she's like
one of the best
accountants in the country,
or something crazy like that.
But what is that thing that you
were doing when you were young
that you stopped doing
because people maybe said,
oh, you can't make
any money with this?
Or, oh, you can't do x.
And tie that into the thing that
you were the most passionate
about.
Right
So for me, my mom told me
this story when I was one
and I left the house.
I just let myself out.
And I was just walking around.
I was probably
throwing snowballs,
like having a good-- making
snow angels as a one-year-old.
And so she was like,
this was who you were.
You were always
wandering around, trying
to find the newest adventures.
And so I often tell
people, I will go
anywhere that's not war-torn.
And I want everybody
to feel the same way.
That anywhere that you travel
to is your place to travel to.
And you are welcome
in that place.
And so I think that the
mission of Travel Noire
came out of that.
Like, you also belong here.
Just because you don't see--
I grew up in Minnesota.
Minnesota is very white.
I was like one of three
people in my class.
And so I grew up living
a very different life,
like I was this one black
girl with the exotic name.
People were like,
where are you from?
So I shortened my name to
Zim instead of [? Zimusa, ?]
which is my full name.
And then I moved
to North Carolina,
where I was crushing fruit
flies and cloning gene.
There were no other
black girls in my school
who were doing those things.
And so I was always used
to just being the other.
And it took me time to figure
out that that was also OK.
And I wanted everybody
to be able to feel OK
with being other.
And so I think the Travel
Noire mission kind of came out
of that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Hey.
AUDIENCE: You sound like
the emails you send.
Very [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
With all that you
do and the team
that you manage, how do
you find time for self?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Oh.
So I block out--
so a couple of things.
So from like 6:00 AM to 10:00
AM, I have just nothing.
So I usually do a lot of
praying, or reading the Bible,
or studying scripture,
or something like that.
And then, I take a
one-week off per month.
So I take one week off a month.
And that usually doesn't
include vacations.
So I kind of mix
those all in as well.
I am one of the most
restful people you'll meet.
I have friends that I
know that are really busy.
I just have them block off
a month in their calendar
and send me an invite, so I know
that if they change the dates--
you know if you send
somebody a confirmation,
if you change the
time or whatever,
they get the notification.
So if I get any
notification from my friends
that they moved their
ofttimes, I'm calling them
and we're going to have
a serious discussion.
And so I think that
rest is so important.
Because who are
you without rest?
If y'all worked from January
to December with no days off,
y'all would be frizzle,
frazzle, shaken, gray hair,
hair falling out, everything.
And you wouldn't be
of no use to anybody.
And so I think that of the
things that I've learned,
you have some entrepreneurs that
are like, work till you die.
Sleep.
Like whatever.
Like don't sleep ever.
And I'm like, what?
That doesn't make any sense.
So I think that I've been very
intentional about the time
that I have to myself.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for being here.
First of all, I
would like to know
what's next for Travel Noire?
And maybe, are there
any other industries
with a lack of representation
of people of color
that you're looking into
branching into maybe?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: That's
actually, a good question.
So for TN experiences,
more destinations.
We're launching a new
destination this summer.
We're also looking at
different segments.
So I know that I've gone
to a lot of conferences
where people who are
50-plus for instance,
will be like, I want
to go to your trips.
Everybody on those trips look
like they're my children.
They could be my kids.
And so things like that.
There are always places that
need more representation,
I think.
We've thought about interiors.
I mean, travel kind of
like intersects a lot
of different industries in
really interesting and unique
ways.
So those are some of the
things that we're thinking
about in terms of what's next.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Hey.
AUDIENCE: When you were talking,
you talked about execution
and how that's important
for entrepreneurship.
And when you answered
your question,
you talked also about
taking time for yourself
and having rest.
And I feel like
most of us always
have this illusion
that we're going
to do what's important now
and we're going to rest later.
Were you like this since 1, or
did you have this moment of--
I think in six months when
it's going to take off,
I'll rest then?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: I was
actually working--
so when I moved to San
Francisco, I had the four jobs.
So I was like a crazy person.
And then when I got my
full-time job as a producer
in San Francisco, and
I started Travel Noire,
I did those two
jobs simultaneously.
So I would work on Travel
Noire from 6:00 AM to 9:00 AM,
go to work from 9:00 to 5:00,
and then work on Travel Noire
from 5:00 to midnight.
And then, like do it all over
again, until I got myself sick.
And I wound up in a hospital.
And then I realized like,
you can't do that forever.
Like Hustle isn't
sustainable forever.
There is a period and a
time and a place for it,
but it can't be
an everyday thing.
And so then, that
was maybe in May.
So then I was like, all right.
So Travel Noire is
doing pretty good.
I've saved up
enough money to be--
well, it wasn't enough.
I mean, whatever.
It's relative.
But I was like, OK.
So there has to be a time
limit for working these two
jobs simultaneously.
They're both full-time jobs.
And so July was my date that
I was going to say, all right.
I'm out of here.
But my boss had other plans.
So yeah, I think
in the beginning,
it was very much like
work, work, work.
Work, work, work
all the time, 24/7.
But then you get sick and
you can't work anymore.
If you don't give
your body rest,
your body's going to
force you to rest.
And at the point where your
body is forcing you to rest,
you're like, just
no good to anybody.
And so it's a
lesson that I've had
to learn time and time again in
those periods of like working,
working, working.
My body is like, all
right, not today.
And you just have to listen
because you can't do anything.
So I think it's a constant
lesson that as entrepreneurs,
you're taught all the time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
last question, sorry.
Do you think the idea is more
important than the execution,
or is the execution [INAUDIBLE]
important than the idea?
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Execution.
Execution is more
important than the idea.
Because listen, when
I was living in India,
I had a spreadsheet of all
these ideas that I had.
80% of them now exist today.
I just had these ideas.
And I was like, oh.
I could be an idea machine.
But if I don't execute on
them, they're just there.
They just exist.
And execution, like
you could find ideas.
You could find ideas anywhere.
But if you have an
execution mindset, then
any idea that comes your
way you can make happen.
Execution.
PENDO O'DONOHOE:
Well, on that note,
I'll say thank you so
much for coming in.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Thank you.
PENDO O'DONOHOE: I think it's
been an inspirational talk
on so many different levels.
You've taught us that we
should follow our dreams, first
and foremost.
You had this wanderlust
biting at the age of one,
which is pretty amazing.
But also, the
importance of rest.
And that it's not easy
to be an entrepreneur.
Running your own business
is not the nirvana
that some people think it is.
But if you really hold on
and challenge yourself,
and create a culture
within your own company,
it could be something that
your dreams are made of.
So thank you again.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: You
are a good summary.
Like you have good summaries.
I could never do that.
PENDO O'DONOHOE: I'm going
to tell stories for you.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: I can't
even remember what I
talked about five minutes ago.
That's cool.
Thank you.
PENDO O'DONOHOE: Brilliant.
Thanks again.
ZIM UGOCHUKWU: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]